all right let's start headlines with the
Buffalo Bills who were in their fans who
were a common story on the old Rosenthal
and Jeselnik vanity project because
they're fans we're always in the news
for their crazy acts tailgating and a
lot of oral sex a lot of just sex
jumping on tables guys on fire just like
they were the craziest tailgating fans
in the league and he kept escalating it
was like they had to top each other
right like stop letting tables on fire
and jumping through them and I just made
them do it all you know it's wild I mean
it was yeah just people having sex right
out in the open all over the never
really got seriously hurt either wasn't
like a Dodger Stadium like someone gets
beat to death after every game right
but these it was like it was
embarrassing to Buffalo it was like he
stopped getting caught on fire but in a
humorous way the bills are have been
trying to curb this the last couple
seasons and they finally have come out
with an official policy that will
require buses and limo buses to purchase
a tailgating package to get into an area
that they I think are calling
essentially like a tailgating zone but
it's gonna be tailgate village but it's
gonna be more organized by the team it's
gonna have you know music acts and stuff
like that and people are gonna have to
pay to get in it and it's all set up to
curb wild tailgating this is why I love
the story is that it is not going to
work hmm all right like if you go if
you're a crazy person right you're a big
drinker you go out to a bar and you get
lit up and you're acting crazy and
they're like oh my god this person's
getting too crazy you know we're gonna
do we're gonna charge them 50 bucks to
get in the bar if you got to pay 50
bucks to get in the bar then you're
really going buck ass wild you just paid
50 bucks to get in there like I are
gonna tear those musical acts apart they
are going to go so much they're gonna
like be stacking tables lighting them on
fire I guarantee one bills player get
the lid on fire this year oh you think
he's going into the tailgate village I
think they're before the game I think
they're gonna get there early and like
light them up as they try to get into
the game like they are going to take
this as a personal challenge backfire
more than if they were like here's a
free area where you guys are allowed to
come in it's free but you got to sign a
waiver well you know we got a high
police presence but it's like it's free
this is for you
then maybe that would work but to be
like you got to pay a bunch of money to
get your bus it's just gonna make people
sneaking harder and harder stuff and go
crazier you heard us bills fans take
take it as a challenge I mean it came
from a lot of like the companies that
bring fans to the game they were
complaining about it like the limo
companies the bus companies they don't
want to be associated anymore but it
seems like the price point actually was
like a little low you know you could
bring in 60 people on a bus and they're
charging like $10 per I mean how is a 60
person bus charging with $10 per person
like that's a recipe to go nuts yeah
that's the 600 bucks to just be like hey
tee off
you earned it Erica have you have you uh
what's the most embarrassing thing
you've done in tailgates or have you
gotten a lot of - yeah cuz I saw the
pictures I remember last year and this
is you as a relative adult going to
Nashville and the Patriots game and you
guys were yeah we rented a bus there was
we had a bar a bartender on the bus in
the parking lot and this was in
Nashville so we that was pretty crazy
but we've brought kegs and stuff to
Foxborough and especially in the winter
- we've like you know let's stuff on
fire and it's all it's all been safe
fire like like firewood like we've
started fires like in the part like
while we're tailgating yeah have you
been in like a group of people that are
like taking shots out of someone's ass
yeah I mean you haven't well no like
that's not like that's not that crazy I
don't think that crazy but I don't want
to do I'm not taking a shot out of
anyone's ass
near my but I'll tell you what the worst
one I ever did was we went to I think it
was Dave Matthews it was Dave Matthews
my senior year of high school one of my
friends drives and we get a hotel room
right near the the amphitheater where
this of concerts going on it and we buy
a bunch of cases of beer
one of our friends look like he was like
40 years old and we dump we like
put all the beer in the fridge in the
bathtub filled with ice and we're just
like doing beer funnels getting wasted
and we were getting so much beer on
ourselves that we all just got into our
underwear so we're just in our underwear
in this hotel room like 10 guys just
funneling beer is getting so drunk
they're like on the way in and then we
thought my friend is just puking out the
window he's puking out the window
everyone singing I drink too much I eat
too much too much as my friends throwing
up and then we pull up we're like in
line to get into the actual place and
I'm like I've got to go to the bathroom
so badly that I open up this van door
the sliding van door and I run into the
bushes and I'm peeing and I hear a cop
be like hey you public urination stop
and I turn and I go to run back into the
van and I almost make it like I get into
the van where like the top of the van
just hits me right like a box like right
and like the middle of the forehead and
just I was I was running full sprint and
just a band right into the forehead did
the cop let me go he just like saw me on
the ground it was like huge red mark and
was just like get out of here kid like
you're like that's punishment enough you
can you can you can go home that was my
worst tailgating story a shooting
occurred this week where a man 69 years
old was shot while he was in line buying
groceries by mistake by his 67 year old
wife it was in her purse it was in her
purse to drop the purse and it shot him
in the leg he tried he tried to blitz
right to say he shot himself by mistake
you try to take blame and then they
figured out what it would have what
happened listen I don't want to sound
sexist Erica you know I love you all the
female listeners we have both of you
guys are great I don't want it son
sexist but this is exactly why women
should not be allowed to have guns
women should not be allowed to own a gun
they shouldn't be allowed to carry a gun
and all men should have to carry purses
all men should wear purses at all times
different kinds of persons not just like
a masculine purse but like crazy weird
purses because it's their responsibility
women give it up you can't be president
you can't carry a gun and men get your
purses what do you thing about that
Erica yeah I'm all for it
I carry a purse I do I mean it feels a
little hard like maybe four I don't
carry all the time we're gonna
definitely cuz you shouldn't have one
you should give that purse to me give me
all your purses you got I'd be like The
Punisher with just like a bunch of
purses
it's like fanny packs not cool but if
you got a purse it sounds like why you
care in that person be like you know I'm
carrying that purse people know you've
got a gun I mean they're not
around it feels unfair to you know
punish the entire gender' from the joy
of carrying around concealed weapons
especially 67 year old women just cuz
Lily and messy air you know messed up if
you can business things get taken away
everybody you know what I mean
that's what America is all about when
something happens with guns in America
America makes some changes right away
they get the Congress gets together and
they're like what are we gonna do every
time there's something with guns that
when this happens I don't I don't think
I'm going far enough by saying that
women can't carry guns anymore and all
men have to carry purses
[Music]
you